let us all for me one of the most
flavorsome flatfish twice as much flavor
as the dover salt and more importantly
half the price skin side down skins just
nip at the end grab it like you're sort
of almost pulling hair and let the knife
do the work season dill dill and fish go
brilliantly because it's got that really
nice sort of fennel flavor that sort of
aniseed flavor and just roll almost like
a sausage links
carrots spring onions garlic it's a very
delicate dainty fish this so we don't
want to overpower the garlic and then
something just sort of waiting it up a
little bit thyme rosemary the time goes
brilliant with the leeks and the rosin
goes fantastic with the carrots baking
paper if I had to put them on my board
like that then they gonna curl up so I
turn the paper almost inside out add veg
we're looking for a bed like a nest of
vegetables
season and then just drizzle generously
with olive oil
it looks delicious now it's not even
cooked taking a piece of paper that goes
over the top wrap you get the top right
hand corner
and you just fold that over and then
over again fold and push I just follow
it round fold and push is left almost
like a little snout
white wine what the wine does as that
salt is steaming there it makes a really
nice aroma with a vegetable olive oil
and keeps everything really nice and
light and fruity see you pan on there
and push down and look just seals the
paper
hot oven 20 minutes and this is the bit
of magic in and just look and look at
that absolutely delicious and a perfume
of the herbs extraordinary soul on
Papillon done the crispy topping you can
see what that deserves to be a great
British classic that has to be the
perfect strong enough smoked paprika
chicken stroganoff
it's pet silly